the mathematics syllabus in Australia is
what we call cyclically it goes round
and round and round the same set of
topics Center ideas but we look at it in
a more breadth and also in more detail
okay that's quite different to say for
example just because we're talking about
before the u.s. system does anyone know
how the u.s. system handles maths then
hmmm that's very differently because for
instance they don't say I'm doing you
nightmares
and then I do you ten months and then so
on they say oh this year I'm taking
algebra let's just behold it the whole
year is algebra that's all they look at
no shapes okay and then the next year
they say I'm doing trigonometry oh oh
I'm doing precalculus now or they
trigonometry you're a single idea and
they go around around around around on
that same idea and then they move on to
a whole different topic
we're different we've seen simultaneous
equations before and now I got to look
at it again but in more breadth and also
in more detail okay I want you to look
at the two questions that we looked at
this morning the first thing I point out
is that they're linear equations right
and the second thing I wanna point out
is how many equations did you get each
time - so we call them these systems of
pairs of linear equations okay so in the
past you've had pairs of linear
equations so the way that we're going to
expand on that this year is number one
that's a period zero will be about
instead of looking at pairs we won't
make it too bad for you we're going to
flip this on systems of not two but
three equations together
they get a look at how to solve buzz and
in addition to expanding in that
direction we're also going to expand in
this direction these are all straight
lines whatever pair of equations you
have before you could draw it like this
okay waiting to look at nonlinear
equations and solving them some paisley
so things like parabolas and
Exponential's log curves trigonometric
functions all that kind of thing I
prepared zero this is just what we're
going to look at the first thing I want
you to notice as you look is that these
are still linear equations there are no
no powers no variables being divided or
anything like that so we're still
looking at straight kinds of these
straight objects however when you get
three equations what comes along for the
ride is a third variable do you notice
that we've got Zed's flying around okay
now that raises two questions number one
what is it our third variable is okay
yeah
hmm that's right okay now think about
this right you don't need to redraw this
because you have it in front of you but
I just wrote it off remember we just
solved or we confirmed our solution for
a pair of linear equations in this way
we graphed and then we graph and we were
like cool look they intersect okay now
if I add it on for you a third equation
which still has two variables if you
wanted to solve that evening is a
solution presumably it will go through
that same point there is only one to
choose from okay now alternatively I
could give you a third equation and it
might not go through there what would
that mean if the third equation for
example was this if I gave you three
questions two variables and X to the Y
and you graph them and they look like
that how would you answer that question
with solving simultaneous equations
maybe back to a beginner lesson you are
searching for the values of x and y that
satisfy all three of those equations
okay in other words we're looking for a
point that is on all three of your lines
how many points can you see that are on
all three lines and so there are none I
can see three points one two three that
will be on two out of the three but
there's nothing on that particular
picture whether we can all three at the
same time okay so in other words no
matter what values next and why you find
you can put them into all three
equations you'll ever solve all of them
okay so there be no solution in that
case therefore when you come to this
right if two variables gives you a
straight line what is three variables
give you
when you have an X in the wine right
you've got an X and a y-axis each
variable gives you a new dimension you
can move in so if I give you a third
variable that maybe it means you have
three dimensions
now I'm limited because I'm drawing on a
whiteboard okay but if you can picture
that going off into the distance like
into the whiteboard and coming out of
the whiteboard all you're doing is
instead of solving where you do two
straight lines what point do they
intersect
what you're doing is you're saying well
okay where do these three not lines but
plane means where do these planes
intersect with each other so just think
about these if I gave you two planes
right and I said okay let it's offered
an angle okay now I know I've only got
finite planes so you do it
if these planes went in all directions
so this one goes up and left and sorry
left and right and down in all
directions and the same with this one
what kind of intersection would you get
between these two surfaces think about
it
do you see if I hold it kind of this way
it's going to be a single line that goes
through both surfaces everywhere do you
agree with that be a single line okay
now if I add a third surface in which I
can't because I don't have enough hands
but adding a third surface there's only
going to be one point on that line that
cuts your final surface does that make
sense and that's the value that you're
looking for it's an x and a y and is it
all right suggestion what's the first
thing I should write on here to start
solving very very first thing
I better name these things right one -
great okay now where before we had three
sort of tools we could use you could do
elimination substitution or if you
wanted to you could grab okay in this
case
well for starters graphing is pretty
much taken out of the out of the picture
because it's just too hard to draw the
elimination is also very difficult can
anyone tell me why correct
do you remember the one the example I
gave it was something like I remember
the numbers now something like this
it's immaterial okay yeah it's like oh
how nice
plus y minus y I can just come out in
the wash really really quickly okay here
if you want to eliminate things out
you're gonna have to have so many things
line up it's always going to be sort of
ridiculous to have something that nice
to start with okay so really the only
tool you've got is substitution okay so
have a look you can start anywhere you'd
like just for the sake of consistency
I'm gonna go after next I mean there's a
y&z there but exit alphabetical so one I
don't really know in advance which one's
going to be the easiest to solve